una legislación sin precedentes que
allana el camino para una votación
histórica en Australia la decisión Del
senado dicta que los australianos
votarán en referéndum para decidir si
modifican o no la Constitución creando
un grupo de defensa de los derechos
indígenas
a mis compatriotas australianos les digo
que los parlamentos aprueban leyes pero
son las personas las que hacen la
historia Este es su momento su
oportunidad su ocasión de contribuir a
hacer historia
Michael history el comité propuesto
denominado voz al parlamento defenderá
los intereses indígenas sus partidarios
dicen que mejorará el nivel de vida de
los indígenas que constituyen algo más
del 3% de la población australiana y que
son el grupo étnico más desfavorecido
del país pero Quienes se oponen a la
propuesta afirman que el grupo no tendrá
ningún poder real a la hora de elaborar
leyes
no necesito la culpa blanca de nadie y
de eso se trata se trata de apaciguar la
culpa de los blancos en este país
dando a los pobres negritos un órgano
consultivo sin poder
la última vez que los australianos
votaron en un referéndum fue en 1999
cuando los votantes rechazaron una
propuesta para destituir a la difunta
Reina Isabel como jefa de estado y crear
una República el Primer Ministro de
Australia tiene ahora que fijar la fecha
del referéndum a más tardar dentro de
seis meses
[Música]